>>Janis Bell: Thanks, I'm happy that so many
of you are interested in talking grammar and
punctuation.
I'm going to tell you briefly, or as an overview,
what my book addresses. And it doesn't address
grammar from the ground up. It's not everything
anybody ever learned about grammar or needs
to know.
It covers just the mistakes that people usually
make or the problems that they usually encounter
in the sentences that they write. And it really
doesn't matter what you're writing whether
you're writing for business or you're writing
an email to a friend or you're writing something,
an academic paper. I mean sentences are sentences.
Fiction doesn't count; poetry doesn't count;
you can do what you want, you're home free.
But when you're writing about situations that
have occurred or are occurring or will occur,
then grammar and punctuation do count.
So I'll tell you how my book progresses.
It has seven chapters. Now let me start at
the end.
The seventh chapter is on punctuation and
it describes every mark that you'll need when
you write in business correspondence or for
your school papers or whatever emails to friends.
It tells you what the marks do and what they
won't do.
It tells you the common mistakes that people
make; the confusion that people have sometimes
between a semicolon and a colon, for example,
or between a dash and a hyphen.
That's, that's a very common confusion that
I run into; people typing a hyphen and thinking
that it's a dash. You know what I'm talking
about? A hyphen is the smallest horizontal
line that you can find on your keyboard and
in order to create a dash, which is a very
different mark you need to hit that hyphen
key twice typically. Sometimes it closes up
on the screen, sometimes it doesn't. But that,
that's a dash and it does something very different
from what hyphens do.
So people do run into confusion when it comes
to punctuation. As a matter of fact, I would
say most people couldn't tell you how to use
a comma. Certainly in some sentences we know
where commas belong, but questions arise.
People typically ask, "Well do you need the
comma before 'and' when you have three or
more items in a series?" In the writing that
you're reading, the professional writing that
has been professionally written and edited,
sometimes you'll see that comma and sometimes
you won't. I don't know whether you pay attention
to that kind of thing, of course I do.
But that can be confusing. You know, how come
Time Magazine is not putting it in and the
New Yorker is putting it in? If you take a
look at sentences that contain items in a
series.
The rule is, just to answer that question
right now, that you do put it in. That it
gives equal attention to all the items in
a series without making the last two look
more related than any others. That's the tradition,
that's the original rule. Many publications
follow it and yet some authors and editors
and publications are choosing not to follow
it. So that's why you see it both ways. I
follow the rule. I, I think it makes sense;
not just because I like rules, although I
do; but because it makes sense in that it
gives every item equal attention and there's
no lack of clarity communicating that the
last two items are somehow more related than
the first two, or the first three, anyhow.
So the last chapter does cover all the typical
questions and issues that arise with the different
punctuation marks.
But the rest of the book; the first six chapters
are about grammar and usage.
You know there are certain ways in which we
use words that are not strictly a grammar
matter, but a usage matter. Let me be more
specific. Sometimes with prepositions, you
know those little words like "of," "to," "from,"
"around," "about," "above," "beyond," "below,"
"past," "by," "under," "over," those little
words?
We have a lot of idioms. For example we can
be confused "by" something, we can be confused
"over" something, I believe, I'm probably
acceptable, but we can't be confused "to"
something. Now that's not grammar. I mean
the grammar's the same with those three examples.
But the usage is not. I mean it's just that
we're never confused "to" are we? We're confused
"by," we're concerned "over," sometimes we
can be confused, oh "in relation to" and we
can have all kinds of connecting words that
follow "confused," but "to" isn't one of them.
So my book does cover a couple of usage issues
too.
The first chapter covers case. I'm sorry to
use this grammar term and I'll tell you what
it is. I did use regular grammar terms because
if I had to replace them I would have to use
words like "hot dog" and "hamburger" and then
you'd have to remember throughout the book
that a, a "hot dog" is an adjective and a
"hamburger" is an adverb and it seemed to
me just the same trouble, so I used the regular
words.
Case refers to forms of pronouns. You know,
is it "I" is it "me" is it "myself?" Right?
"Steven invited Susan and I to dinner." No.
"Steven invited Susan and me to dinner. " Yes.
Susan, "Steven invited Susan and myself to
dinner," which is a very common error these
days using myself when it should be "I" or
when it should be "me." That's not correct
either. When do we use "myself?" Well that's
the kind of thing that Chapter One does cover.
Chapter Two is called, "Agreement" and it
has to do with subjects and verbs. You remember
those? And agreement refers to number. So
if the subject is plural the verb has to be
in a plural form. If the subject is singular,
etc. Sounds pretty simple and basic; you learned
it a long time ago; you get it right most
of the time.
But there are situations that confuse us or
situations that we don't handle correctly.
We aren't even confused; we just don't know
what's goin' on.
There are some nouns that are singular and
plural in Latin ways that not everybody's
familiar with; for example, "media." You know
very few people are handling that right these
days. "Media" is plural. "The media are represented
here today." And the singular is "medium."
Of course nobody talks about a newspaper correspondent
as coming from a "medium," but that is the
singular.
Another common confusion is over "criteria"
and "criterion." The "o-n" word again is singular
and "criteria" is plural. And yet you hear
people saying, "There's one criteria that
we must follow here." Right? And I always
think, "Oh my goodness sake."
So there are words like that. "Data" is another
one. "Data" is actually plural and so it should
be the "data are" not the "data is." And that
chapter on agreement covers that kind of issue.
What's really plural, what's really singular.
There are many words in our language that
never take an "s," and yet they can represent
groups, right? Many elements like "information"
and "jewelry" and "advice" and "furniture."
And if English is your native tongue you know
that automatically. Nobody had to teach you
that, you've never heard those words with
an "s" on the end. So it's easy to select
the right verb.
But if it's not your native tongue, imagine
it's difficult to come to a language where
usually you can put an "s" on the end of the
word and make it plural. And yet there are
all these exceptions. So if it's not your
native tongue and you're rather new to English,
"advices" probably sounds fine to you. "Informations"
probably not. "Jewelrys," "furnitures," probably.
So the book does address issues like that
too that crop up for non-native speakers,
but primarily it's for native speakers; it's
for educated native speakers; it's for people
who know their language as you do and have
to write.
When we speak we of course make mistakes.
Speaking is a much more rapid activity. We
just don't have the time to think about the
proper grammar and usage beforehand. And when
we speak we have a lot more going for us then
when we write. We have facial expressions,
we've got this hand that waves around and
the other one that holds the microphone. We've,
we've got going for us that we are speaking
at our own pace and the reader, or excuse
me, the listener is trying to follow us and
so that person doesn't have a lot of time
to think about our grammar or our word choice
[laughs] because they're busy keeping up just
trying to get the message.
And yet when we write we have a lot more time
to create what the message is. And the reader
has a lot more time to get it. The reader's
going at his or her pace.
Ah, there's something else that crops up in
the agreement chapter. Pronouns have to agree
with an earlier noun. I just said, "The reader
is going at his or her pace," and that gets
kind of cumbersome, huh? And yet you can't
just pretend the whole world is male anymore.
Well, it probably was never so that you could
pretend it in your life time, but in my life
time, in the beginning, in writing the masculine
pronoun was perfectly acceptable and that's
all you ever saw. But there are ways around
that, and the second chapter does address
them.
Anytime you get into that "he," "she," "him,"
"her," "his," "her" bind you have to realize
it's because you're the one who chose to say
"reader" earlier in that sentence, or "visitor"
or "listener" or "user." Right? If you go
back and make that word plural "readers,"
"visitors," "listeners," "users" then you
can follow it up with "they" and "them" and
"their" and you're out of the "he/she" bind.
[pause]
The third chapter's on verb tense and native
speakers of English don't have that many problems
with tense. It's just automatic, we use present
when we need it, past when we need it, future
when we need it. We know how to form them.
We've been hearing them our whole lives. But
we do have some problems with verb tense and
those are represented here.
For example, if you read an article yesterday
you'd be inclined to write or say about it
that the article "reported" something, right?
And yet that article is still reporting something.
It's that you read it yesterday and that past
tense is in your memory and so you are saying
that the article "reported that Google did
something." Well it could be that Google did
something in the past, but the article is
still reporting it. So that really should
be present tense. "The article reports" that
Google did something. Kind of interesting.
Those are the kinds of issues that native
speakers have with tense and those crop up
in Chapter Three.
Let's see, case, agreement, tense. Mood. There's
something called "mood" in grammar. Not a
good mood or a bad mood, but specifically
a subjunctive mood. Never mind you really
don't need the terminology. Let me tell you
what it translates into.
When we're speculating about something, we
have a choice. We are trying to convey to
the listener or the reader that either what
we're speculating about is possible or what
we're speculating about is impossible, but
we're speculating anyway.
For example, "If I were from Los Angeles I
would be chilly up here." "If I were from
Los Angeles I would be chilly up here." You
can hear from my verbs "were" and "would"
that I'm not from Los Angeles, right? Now
if I change that sentence and, and say, "If
Carol is from Los Angeles she is surely chilly
up here," now you probably get the message
that it's possible that Carol's from Los Angeles.
"If Carol is from Los Angeles she is probably
chilly up here." Do you hear it? It's possible
that she's from LA. Can you hear that possibility?
Let me change the other sentence back into
Carol because it should be consistent. I started
with "I." The reason I had switched over to
"Carol" is if I don't know whether Carol's
from Los Angeles but its possible, then I
can use "is." If she "is" from Los Angeles
then she "is" probably chilly, right? But
I can't speculate that way about me. I know
where I'm from. So that's why I had to switch
over to "Carol." Do you see?
So let me put her in the subjunctive. "If
Carol were from Los Angeles she would be chilly
up here." Now you should be getting the message
that she's not from LA, right? If she "were"
from LA she would do something. If she "is"
from LA she "is" probably a certain way. The
sentence involving "were" and "would" should
be conveying the message to you that it's
not happening. I'm speculating about it anyway,
but it's not happening. It's contrary to fact.
And the other sentence should be conveying
to you that it's possible. I just don't know.
"If she is a dancer, she probably needs money."
"If she were a dancer she would need money."
You hear the difference?
[pause]
That's what this chapter addresses because
typical native speakers don't understand that
we're supposed to be using "were." They're
using "was" in all those situations. They
know they're speculating, but they're using
"was." You know, "If I was there." Well are
you there? No. You're speculating about something
that isn't possible, right? So if I "were"
there not if I "was" there.
Do we have to worry about this with every
sentence? No. There are just certain words
that lead to speculation. "If" is one of 'em.
Everyone sentence involving "if" can be speculating
about something that's not true or speculating
about something that could be true.
"Wish" is another one. "Wish" always leads
to a statement that's contrary to fact or
you wouldn't be "wishing." "I wish I were."
"She wishes he were."
[pause]
No matter who's "wishing" the verb should
be "were." It shouldn't be "was." So the chapter
addresses that.
The next one's on modifiers; a real fancy
term for words that describe. And you might
say, "Oh that's easy. Words that describe,
adjectives, right?" How many of them are adjectives
in fact, but in forms that you were never
told are adjectives?
For example, if I say, "While driving down
the freeway," would you believe that, that,
that whole phrase is an adjective? I'm describing
somebody who's driving down the freeway and
the word in that opening phrase that is the
descriptive word is the word "driving." So
when an opening phrase has an action word,
like "running," "walking," "swimming," "dancing,"
"driving," "researching," "analyzing," "deciding,"
it doesn't matter; that word is trying to
describe somebody or something. It's usually
a somebody and whoever it is has to follow
the phrase.
Let me give you an example and you'll know
that you're gut understands this before your
head does. "Crawling across the yard the snail
intrigued the baby." Who's crawling?
[pause]
"Crawling across the yard the snail intrigued
the baby." Who's crawling? The snail. You
should, well you should think it's the snail.
You have a good imagination if you think it's
the baby. The baby came later. "Crawling across
the yard the snail," hear it? "Intrigued the
baby." So you should be thinking it's the
snail that's doing the crawling. On the other
hand, if I change it and put the baby next
to the crawling phrase, then you'll be right
to assume that it's the kid who's crawling.
"Crawling across the yard the baby followed
the snail."
[pause]
"Crawling across the yard the baby pursued
the snail." Let me change the verb; make it
a little more interesting. "Crawling across
the yard the baby pursued the snail." You
should be understanding that now it's the
baby that's crawling across the yard.
Whoever I put next to that crawling phrase
is gonna wind up crawling. Unless I put a
word there that doesn't crawl and then the
reader goes, "What?" And so maybe the reader
figures it out because he understands the
context and he understands who can crawl and
who can't. Still it's not a good sentence
and it's not a sentence that most of us were
taught about anytime in high school or middle
school or grammar school or even college.
I could have a Ph.D. in English today and
not understand that kind of sentence structure.
And the only reason I really understand all
of these things is that I, during my graduate
studies focused on the teaching of writing.
It's amazing isn't it?
But anyway, it's that kind of thing that crops
up in the mod, modifiers chapter.
There's another really popular one people
saying "like I said," "like I told you." And
that really should be "as I said" and "as
I told you." And of course there's a place
for "like" but not in that particular phrase,
and that chapter explains that.
After that the sixth grammar chapter's on
connectives; words that connect. We've got
prepositions, as I mentioned it before. You
know the "in," "on," "to," "from." The key
question that usually pops us is, is it against
the rule to end a sentence in a preposition?
And I think that's about all anybody ever
remembers about prepositions at that, at some
point somebody told them not to end a sentence
in one. Yet, it's fine to do so as long as
there's a word earlier in the sentence that
goes with that preposition. It's pretty awkward
to always tuck them back in. You can ruin
a whole idiom.
For example, "There were, there are certain
things up with which I will not put." I mean
who writes like that? Who speaks like that?
The idiom is "to put up with." "There are
certain things that I won't put up with."
Okay, that sentence ends in a preposition.
So what? It's grammatically correct. It's
a stylistic choice whether you tuck it in
or put it at the end.
And certainly conjunctions are connectives
too, and, and there are a couple of kinds
of conjunctions and they change the structure
of a sentence. And your punctuation options
are different depending on the kind of conjunction
you're using.
And then there are words very common in the
business world, that are not conjunctions
at all and many people don't realize that.
They're words like "however," "furthermore,"
"nevertheless," "moreover," "besides," "also."
Some of them are small; some of them are larger.
They can show the relationship between two
ideas and they can occur right in the middle
of two sentences, but you need more than a
comma to connect those two ideas. Because
those particular words "however," "furthermore,"
"therefore," "nevertheless," "moreover" they're
not conjunctions. They don't have glue on
them. They're just transition words. They
have meaning; they're wonderful to use stylistically,
and as I say they're very popular in the business
world, but after the first idea the minimum
punctuation you should have is a semicolon.
For example, "I enjoy teaching; however, I'm
not gonna do it for the rest of my life."
Oh. The most common error that I've seen over
the last 35 years of teaching is that people
put a comma before and after that "however."
"I enjoy teaching" comma, "however" comma,
"I'm not gonna do it for the rest of my life."
And that is not Kosher, it's not allowable,
it's not a stylistic option. You don't have
a glue word in the middle. You have a transition
word. It shows the relationship between the
two ideas, but it doesn't join them.
So all you can really do if you want those
two ideas in the same sentence is to put a
semicolon after the first idea. And, yes,
there will be a comma after the "however"
or the "furthermore" or the "therefore" because
they are introductory words. They're introducing
the second idea. Your only other option is
to put a period. You can make two sentences
out of 'em, but people know that. What people
don't understand is that these words don't
join ideas and so if you want the two ideas
in the same sentence, you still need some
glue and the semicolon is that glue.
So that kind of thing is in the connectives
chapter.
Also the notion of parallel structure's in
there; meaning items in a series have to match
because whenever you have connecting words,
what you connecting, words or phrases or whole
ideas? And they have to match each other.
So you, of course, may not write "Mary Jane
enjoys hiking, baking, and to ski." That's
an error in parallel structure. Items in a
series have to all be parallel, right? And
you may be sitting there thinking, "Oh, easy
I would never write 'Mary Jane enjoys hiking,
baking, and to ski.'" No because those words
are close together and your ear wouldn't allow
it. But when you add more words into the sentence,
which is more typical of business writing
certainly, your ear doesn't always catch the
problem.
So it could be "Mary Jane enjoys hiking on
Mt. Tamalpais in the springtime, baking cookies
whenever it rains, and to ski at Lake Tahoe
in the winter." You see? The ear doesn't catch
it right away. Your ear may be catching it
and you have an excellent ear. Or you may
be aware of the error because I just gave
you the simplified version of it and you're
lookin' for it. But typically when more words
are involved in each of the items people aren't
so sensitive to whether they match each other.
And we really should be.
I just used the word "whether" which reminds
me of another connective issue. Native speakers
of English are always using "if" when we should
be using "whether," typical mistake? "We need
to know 'if' we're gonna proceed with this
project?" No. "We need to know whether we're
gonna proceed with this project." Why? Because
when "or not" is understood, when the word
"or not" can be placed into the sentence,
you don't have to write it and you don't have
to say it.
But when you can place it in there that means
the connecting word you need is "whether."
So "We need to know whether 'or not' we're
going to proceed with this project." Not "if."
"If" sets up a condition. "If we proceed with
this project we're gonna need more money."
In other words, upon a certain condition "we're
gonna need more money." So that distinction
is also made in the connectives chapter.
And the last chapter as I told you is punctuation.
You may be saying, "Oh my God, all these little,
tiny, picky, nitty gritty things." That's
English for you. It's probably any language,
but here we are with English.
And actually it's a very thin book as you
can see. So it's obviously not covering everything
that could be covered under the sun about
this language, but believe me because I've
been in the classroom with people, in business
settings, and at universities, and private
organizations, and government agencies for
so long I do understand what even good writers
don't always know. And that's what's in this
book.
Anyhow, I'll bet you you've got some questions
and I would love to answer them. So if you
do, please speak up.
[pause]
Yes.
>>male in audience: So language evolves over
time with people using it perhaps incorrectly
so "whom" is probably gonna become "who,"
right? And there are other things like "less"
and "fewer," right? Like the grocery store
you would check out is like "eight items or
less" when it should be "eight items or fewer,"
right? Is this kind of thing ongoing and will
"fewer" become obsolete?
>>Janis Bell: Well I'm not a soothsayer. I
don't know what will and won't become obsolete.
"Whom" is still with us. Professional writers
and editors are still using "whom" and that's
discussed in Chapter One of my book.
I can't say, "Oh forget about it." You could
avoid it and get around it and reword the
sentence so that you don't need it. Sometimes,
to be honest, I don't use it where it belongs.
I'll reword the sentence because it sounds
a little stuffy. And that's not the tone I
want. Other times it's fine. Like "whom did
you vote for?" I mean that's fine with me.
It doesn't sound too bad. But other times
I, I, I will rewrite the sentence just because
of the tone of "whom." It may disappear, and
I, I understand that's your question.
"Fewer" versus "less." Have you seen the grocery
stores lately? You know about eight months
ago I went into a Trader Joe's and it said
"eight items or less" and I went up to the,
[laughs] I'm, I'm crazy, I'm busy. I went
[laughs] up to the Customer Service Department
I said, "You know that really should be 'fewer.'
It shouldn't be 'less.' It really should be
-- " And then I went back to that Trader
Joe's in a couple of weeks and they hadn't
changed the sign. Months later all the signs
at the Trader Joe's were changed to "fewer."
Whole Foods had "fewer" to begin with. I mean
the word "fewer" in their signs. They were
correct, right on, of course they would be.
So, you know, some do; some don't. Will it
disappear? I don't know. You know grammar
seems to be coming back. People seem to be
caring about the correct use of the language
and who knows?
Nothing has changed in my lifetime. Let me
put it that way. We're talking about six decades
here. Nothing has changed in my lifetime except
a punctuation issue.
When I was about 30, people, I mean publishers
were putting periods and commas inside or
outside closing quotation marks depending
on what they belonged to. And then it changed.
And so now when it's time for a comma or a
period and it's also time for a closing quotation
mark, that comma or period goes inside, don't
even think about it. Well what if the sentence
is 25 words long and only the last word's
in quotes. I said, "Don't think about it.
Just put the period in inside," because there's
not an option in this country.
And I say this country because that's what
we do here it's not what they do in England
or Australia or Canada, but it is what we
do here.
That's the only thing that's changed. What
a long answer to a short question.
What else? Yes.
>>female in audience: What do you think can
be done in schools to teach these rules better?
'Cause it seems that a lot of English teachers
teach you the basic rules but are kind of
lax about some of the, some of the structures
here.
>>Janie Bell: I think all the schools should
just order my book and use it.
[laughter]
Seriously, I wish I had a way. You know my
book so far has not been marketed to schools.
My publisher didn't aim for schools; they
aimed for the marketplace for the ordinary
individual who has to write which is practically
everybody. And I'm not averse to that. I,
I like it being everywhere and in all bookstores,
but, and on Amazon, but I, I wish it, I wish
it were marketed, I wish is had been marketed
to the schools because I think that a, a book
like this would be immensely useful.
And you're right to say that teachers are,
did you say lax?
>>female in audience: Yeah.
>>Janis Bell: I'm not sure they're lax. I'm
not sure they know all of the information
that they should really be con, conveying.
It's a, it's a specialized field. And as I
said a moment ago, if I hadn't specialized
in the teaching of writing as a graduate student,
had I not planned on teaching writing at the
college level, I would be one of those teachers
too. You know understanding the language pretty
well on a gut level, but not really under,
not being able to communicate it really clearly
as to why it's this way.
The word "why" reminds me of something else
and that happens in the connectives chapter.
"The reason why is because." Oh what a common
locution these days. If you're using reason
you don't need to say "why" and you don't
need to say "because." It's redundant. They
all three mean the same thing.
So if you've begun a sentence with "reason"
don't use "why" and don't say "is because."
The little connecting word you need is "that."
"The reason I was late today is 'that' there
was a lot of traffic." Not, "the reason I
was late 'is because' there was a lot of traffic."
And not "the reason why I was late is because
there was a lot of traffic." Do you understand
what's going on? "Reason" says it all. If
you don't have the word "reason" you can use
the word "because," if you don't have "reason"
or "because" you can use the word "why;" but
not together.
Sorry. I mean sorry. I digress.
Another question.
Yes, in the back.
[pause]
Wait one moment you're gonna get a booming
voice.
>>male in audience: Can you talk a little
bit about active versus passive verbs? I was
always told in school to avoid passive verbs
like the plague and to just structure your
sentences to always be, to always include
an active verb. Can you talk a little bit
about that?
>>Janice Bell: I can talk a lot about that.
I'm not sure you'd wanna hear it.
By the way, it's not covered in my book because
active and passive voice, I'm glad you called
it "voice" and not "tense." Usually people
call it "tense" which is isn't, are matters
of style. This is style were talking about
here. The active voice is correct and the
passive voice is correct and you know what
else these days there's, there's not a huge
problem of people using the passive when they
should be using the active. We've sort of
come over that hump in our society.
When I began teaching writing in organizations
and in businesses, the passive voice was all
too prevalent and now it's really not. So
we can prove.
For those of you who are sitting there thinking,
"What the heck are they talking about?" Anytime
you have an idea you're going to have a subject
and a verb, even the simplest of ideas. You
know, "The dog ate the bone." You've got somebody
at the beginning and you have an action happening.
If that somebody at the beginning is doing
the action, and by the way, tense has nothing
to do with this, it doesn't matter whether
"the dog ate the bone yesterday," whether
"he is eating it presently," whether he "will"
eat it tomorrow, or whether he "had" eaten
it before I did something else. That dog is
the agent of the action regardless of when
it took place. That whole idea is said to
be written in the active voice.
So, "The dog ate the bone" is active. It also
has nothing to do with meaning. If I say,
"The man lay dead on the floor" that's active.
People go, "But, but he's dead." I told you
it had nothin' to do with meaning. Did the
man do the lying on the floor? Did the man
lie on the floor? I said "the man lay." "Lay"
why, because that's the past tense of "l-i-e"
believe it or not. That's in my book too.
Anyhow. But that's an active sentence because
the man "did" the "lying" on the floor. The
man did the action.
Whether the dog "eats the bone" now, "will
eat it tomorrow," or "did eat it yesterday,"
he's doing the action; that's called active.
If I turn it around and start that same idea
with the bone I'm gonna get what we call passive.
And I'll tell you why in a moment.
"The bone was eaten by the dog," same idea,
right? But now I've got the "bone" in the
subject position. Grammatically it's the subject
and psychologically it's the subject. When
I say, "The bone was eaten by the dog" you
should be getting the message that this sentence
is about the bone. It's kind of incidental
that the guy who ate it is the dog, right?
"The dog ate the bone." Subject: dog; focal
point: dog. "The bone was eaten by the dog."
Subject: bone; focal point: bone, right?
That's called passive because the new subject
"bone" didn't do the eating. "The bone was
eaten." "It was considered." "It had been
decided." "It was recommended." You hear those?
Those are typically passive constructions.
The subject of those last three examples is
"it." And yet "it" didn't do the deciding
or the recommending or the considering, right?
Who did? And this is why the gentlemen in
the back was told awhile back by teachers
"avoid the passive voice."
We don't always need to avoid the passive
voice. It's just that it's a lot better style
to say "who recommended," "who decided," "who
considered" in the business world. And lately
people know that and they're not hiding. They're
not saying, "It is recommended that something
be done." They're saying, "Management recommends
that we do something," right? Isn't that more
typical in the work environment now? Great.
We got over a, one problem in this society.
So that's probably, well that's one of the
rea, reasons teachers were telling you to
stay away from passivity. The other thing
is a passive idea, "The bone was eaten by
the dog" always requires more words than an
active idea. "The dog ate the bone." You hear
it?
[pause]
Five for "dog ate the bone;" seven for "The
bone was eaten by the dog."
Because to create a passive verb you have
to add a "was" or an "is" or a "will be" before
another verb. "Was eaten" versus "ate." And
then to tell who did it if you're gonna give
all the information you've gotta add a little
"by" at the end.
Now passivity comes in handy however when
this whole paragraph's gonna be about the
bone. And I don't mind telling you who ate
it, but I'm not gonna start by putting the
spotlight on the dog when the rest of the
focus will be on the bone.
So that would be a good time to say, "The
bone was eaten by the dog." I could add, you
might say, "Oh that's such a simple sentence."
Well I'm trying to give you the skeletal version
so you'll understand the answer to the question.
I can add more details. I can say, "Under
the shade of a magnolia tree in 1938 the bone
was eaten by the dog with great gusto."
[pause]
Still passive, there's only one subject and
verb. I just gave you a lot of description
telling you when and where and how that bone
was eaten. But it's still passive because
that bone was still eaten and if the rest
of the paragraph or report is about the bone
then that's a good choice.
There's another time passivity's very useful
and that's when we don't know who ate the
bone. So, but we do know it was eaten. So,
"Under the shade of a magnolia tree in Southeastern
Alabama in 1938 the bone was eaten with great
gusto." You see? It's useful when we don't
know who did what the passive voice serves
us well.
I would say that as a group you don't need
to think about this although I did wanna answer
your question and it may have been interesting
for some of you too.
But mostly now we're using active voice telling
who does what, who did what, who would do
what if she could do what, appropriately.
And we are using passive voice automatically
when we wanna shift the focus onto "the phone
went unanswered." "The phone was unanswered."
You know I, I have no interest in saying,
"Who didn't answer the phone?" That's not
my point; I'm saying, "The phone was unanswered,"
right? So I think it's pretty automatic now
and I think we're in good shape. But, does
that help?
[pause]
Another question?
>>female in audience: Hi, I'm curious to hear
your opinion on corporate buzz words. So here
we say a lot of terms that maybe are changed
from their original meaning to sound more
corporate. So some examples are "take aways,"
"learnings." Like, "What are the learnings
from this presentation?"
One thing that we say a lot on my team is
"bottom lining." So instead of saying, "What's
the bottom line," we'll say you know, "Make
sure your bottom lining" -
>>Janis Bell: Um-hum.
>>female in audience: or "Make sure you're
working on your bottom lining skills."
>>Janis Bell: Um-hum.
>>female in audience: And it drives me insane.
[laughs]
>>Janis Bell: Does it? I think it's creative.
>>female in audience: But it --
>>Janis Bell: Why not?
>>female in audience: It serves a purpose
and --
>>Janis Bell: It serves a purpose and it also
makes you feel more closely related to your
language that you can change it to suit your
needs. English is very elastic; very flexible;
it's incorporated all kinds of new vocabulary
words since you've been alive, since I've
been alive and long before that.
I think it's great that you can take a word
that used to be just in this form and add
an "ing" and everybody knows what you're talking
about and it's infused with a new life somehow,
so if it suits the organization and everybody
knows what you're talking about and it brings
you a little closer because you're the only
guys who are bottom lining these days, why
not? Although are you? I don't know. You know
you may be starting a trend.
I understand what you are saying that when
things aren't used as we were taught to use
them it can be aggravating, as you say it's
driving you crazy. But you asked me what I
think. It wouldn't drive me crazy. I think
it's adorable. [laughs]
[laughter]
I'd, I'd go right into it if I could. I don't
work for Google so I'm not gonna be bottom
lining, but, it's, it makes one think. It's
refreshing, I think.
That's just my take. Huh? This is just an
opinion, there's no rule.
[pause]
Anybody else?
Yes.
[pause]
>>female in audience: So I'm just tryin' to
wrap my head around a specific example that
you said.
>>Janis Bell: Which one?
>>female in audience: So "data" is plural.
>>Janis Bell: It is.
>>female in audience: So "the data were complicated?"
>>Janis Bell: That's right. And they probably
still are because they still exist. See that's
the other thing about tense --
>>female in audience: So they use is because
it sounds like idiom, like the idiom, like
why do people use "the data is complicated?"
>>Janis Bell: They don't understand that it's
a Latin word that is plural. That's why. It's
just, I think it's really a matter of maybe
ignorance is too harsh a word, but not knowing
how 'bout that, kind of like "bottom lining."
That's what I think. They don't understand
that "data" is plural. The word "data" yeah.
"Phenomena" is plural. So you know to say,
"This is a new phenomena" is not right, "phenomenon"
with an "o-n."
These are just words that come from Latin
we still have them in our language, as they
were born. They didn't change a whit and you
know we get used to a lot of, a lot of mistakes
and so they don't sound bad anymore.
For example probably "like I said" doesn't
bother you at all. It, you're used to it.
Hardly anybody says, "as I said," you know.
So may, perhaps before I began to speak you
weren't bothered by "the reason why we did
this is because funding was short at the time."
Maybe that would, wouldn't have bothered you
either. Maybe it won't bother you in the future.
God bless you, how wonderful. [laughs] It
bothers me terribly.
So what, when we get used to hearing something
over and over and over we think it's fine
and then somebody comes up and says, "No,
it's not" and that's gonna bother you for
awhile, surely comma, surely period.
[laughter]
Who else? Yes.
[pause]
>>male in audience. So I had a quick question.
I see this a lot of times in English and I
wasn't sure if it was correct, but a lot of
times I'll see something like, "I want to
tell you," or "I want to write you to let
you know," or along those lines -
>>Janis Bell: Uh-huh.
>>male in audience: but they use the past
tense with "I wanted."
>>Janis Bell: Oh yes. It, again remember a
moment ago I was saying that because we read
something in the past we tend to ascribe past
tense to that thing like, "The article stated"
or "The report implied" and we have to remember,
no I read it in the past but the article is
still "stating" and the report is still "implying"
and they should be present tense.
Same thing happens when we write sentences
like the one that you just gave. "I wanted
to let you know." Well don't you still want
to let the person know? It's a habit and everybody's
fallen into it and it sounds fine and nobody
looks at it. When you do look at it though
you realize you don't need an "e-d" there;
get rid of it. "I want to let you know." It's,
it's a small change, but you know everything
in my book and everything were talking about
is a small change. You put 'em all together
and they make a big difference in the way
your writing comes across. "I want to let
you know."
Another one along those same lines to use
your phrase is,
[pause]
oh let me see,
um, what is it, something about receiving
your letter. Oh, it's a little different.
"We have received your letter of October 15th."
How many times did you receive that letter?
Because have done something is supposed to
be for repeated past action and if it just
happened once you should be writing, "We received
your letter." That's what that reminds me
of.
But you're right, "I wanted to let you know."
"I wanted to thank you." Oh you don't still
want? You do still want. So you know take
a, take a closer look at it.
I just remembered I'm not supposed to cross
this line which is why I made a face. [laughs]
Anyway, that's a good question.
[pause]
>>male in audience: So you kind of have to
follow up on that. So if you said something
like, "I ate at a great, I ate at a great
rest, I ate at a restaurant last night. The
vibe was great or the vibe, or the atmosphere"
'cause the atmosphere's still there.
>>Janis Bell: Yes.
>>male in audience: So would you say, "The
atmosphere is great" or "was great?"
>>Janis Bell: Well is depends on what you're
counting as atmosphere, if it includes the
people and the particular food that was served
and the fact that there was a party singing
next to you, I don't, it could be a "was."
You know "The vibe was great, the atmosphere
was great." If you're not sure that it still
is great or that it will be when somebody
else goes there you can use the past tense,
so that one's up for grabs.
You, "The dcor is beautiful," probably they
didn't change the dcor in one day. You know
you, we can be careful and, and, and think
about this especially when we write. We don't
always think about all these issues when we
speak and so errors tumble out of our mouths.
But as I say listeners are much more forgiving
than readers. Forgiving, they don't even notice
what we're doing when we're talking they're
just trying to keep up.
But you put it on paper and people do notice.
They don't always know what it is, but they
get a feeling like, "Uh-oh, that read funny."
[laughs] Right? That didn't seem right.
So anyway that's a good question.
[pause]
Any other questions?
>>female in audience: Right here. [laughs]
>>Janis Bell: Right, oh hi.
>>female in audience: Hi, I just wanted to
know your opinion on using contractions in
emails and writing. Is it too informal? That's
kind of what we're taught in college and school
I think, but in business writing.
>>Janis Bell: What do you think I wanna say?
I'm just curious.
>>female in audience: That it's okay.
>>Janis Bell: Yeah. I seem like that kind
of girl don't I? [laughs] It's just fine.
I mean if I like bottom lining why would I
be against contractions?
It really depends on the tone of your document
or the kind of document. If you're writing
to a co-worker or a friend certainly if it's
an informal document you should write as you
speak, for the most part. A little bit better
in that we'll try to get over the errors we
have when we speak. But I think contractions
are, are, are marvelous for that. They mimic
the way in which we ordinarily use the language.
And maybe then if you're writing a formal
report or an analysis of some sort and it's
gonna, it's, it's far reaching or even if
it's not far reaching but it's going to somebody
at the top or somebody who's gonna make a
decision and you want this document to seem
more formal, then don't contract.
Or if you want to emphasis the "not" in a
sentence "We do not put up with this kind
of behavior" rather than "We don't put up
with this," you hear it? It's much more emphatic.
So there are times for spelling out certainly,
but I would say go with what you would do
when you speak. Sometimes we speak more formally
because we're addressing groups or we're talking
about a serious issue and we don't even use
contractions then. So I would go with my gut
if I, if I were you, not if I was you.
[pause]
Yes?
>>male in audience: I'd like to know your
opinion on people who are communicating over
BlackBerry's for business purposes. So typically
out of the office could be late or you know
even early before going to work, are they
excused for contractions like "Thanks, t-h-x"
in those situations or is that an egregious
error?
>>Janis Bell: No, of course it's not an error.
In a space that small what the hell could
you communicate -
[laughter]
if you didn't abbreviate? I mean, and it's,
it's a challenge, it's a new game, it's a
whole new opportunity for your mind to come
up with creative abbreviations that you're
sure your reader will understand, I guess.
That's, so you're not trying to hang the reader
up half a day to understand what you were
talking about. But that's perfectly fine and
logical as a matter of fact, right?
That doesn't fall into the realm of error,
that's deliberate. That's a challenge; that's
fun.
[pause]
>>male in audience: This is kind of in the
same vein and I apologize if you already this,
I got here a little late. In back to back
or back and forth email communication is it
necessary to always say, "Hi, so and so?"
Like,
>>Janis Bell: Get's old doesn't it?
>>male in audience: I mean yeah, I mean if
it's back and forth can you just go right
into what you're about to say?
>>Janis Bell: Well I don't think there are
any rules for this. I can tell you what I
do, that I, I don't say, "Hi so and so" every
time and often I don't even say, "Janis" at
the end. It's like a conversation, right?
The only difference is there's a, a little
bit more of a delay, sometimes not much of
one between what one person says and the other
person says. But if you're going back and
forth like that and it's absolutely clear
what the context is and that other person
knows who's writing and what about, well I
don't see any problem leaving off the "Hi,
Linda" and the "Love, Bill."
>>male in audience: And also do you, do you
recommend any sort of etiquette for correcting
other's grammar. When is that appropriate?
[laughter]
I, I , I, I've always been, I've always understood
that it is not appropriate unless you're an
English teacher to sort of correct someone
else's grammar, but maybe you have a different
opinion.
>>Janis Bell: And it isn't always appropriate
when you're an English teacher either.
I suggest that you give your take on a grammar
situation when somebody asks you. That's what
I suggest.
Even I don't correct people's grammar when
they're writing to me or when they're speaking
to me because first of all they haven't asked
for it and it, it derails the conversation.
Even if I weren't an English teacher or, maybe
it's a little bit more forgivable because
I am as you suggest, but still it, it takes
the conversation into grammar and that's not
what we were talking about. It also probably
makes the person feel ill at le, ill at ease,
if not embarrassed, or maybe even a little
less than friendly toward you, the one who
did it.
But you know there are people who do ask questions,
especially of me and maybe even of you. You
know, "Should it be 'of' should it be 'to,'"
what would you do? Would you say "of" or "to"
here? And sometimes either one works; sometimes
one is preferable and you can certainly give
your answer.
I would have to say what's the situation,
I mean if, if it's a cousin of yours or a
sister or a, a, co-worker whose performance
you're trying to improve, I was, I think I
would still get that person's solicitation.
I would wait for the question. I would wait
for that person to ask me to help out.
Are you inclined to do that? It --
[laughter]
No.
No. I mean I do it in my head. I do it in
my head when people speak, but I'm not gonna
say, "Hey you know that 'if' should have been
a 'whether.'" "Hey you know what you've got
a double negative in that sentence and it
doesn't," "You know what your parallel structure's
off." "You know what you're throwing the word
'only' in too soon every time."
[laughter]
That's such a cute one, by the way. We do
throw the word "only" in too soon most of
the time.
Let me give you a, a sentence with, let me
give you a typical error. "Yesterday I only
rented a Volkswagen." Now I don't know what
kind of meaning you get out of that. Probably
from my inflection, my face, my hand you're
understanding that a Volkswagen is not a very
big car or a very big expenditure or something
like that, it's just a Volkswagen. But what
I actually said is, "Yesterday I only rented,"
that's what I said. That's not the inflection
I gave it, but you're writing doesn't have
inflection. You're writing doesn't have any
tone to it or any verbal emphasis to it. So
if somebody reads, "Yesterday I only rented
a Volkswagen," that's indeed the message that
they may get, that you just rented one, you
didn't buy one.
Look at how the meaning changes depending
on where I put "only." I'm gonna take that
same core sentence. "Only yesterday I rented
a Volkswagen." "Yesterday only I rented a
Volkswagen." "Yesterday I only rented a Volkswagen."
"Yesterday I rented only a Volkswagen." You
see what's happening? "Only" shines its light
to the right, it shines its light on the next
word. So if I say, "Only yesterday," you get
it, oh so recently. If I say, "Only I," you
get it, no one else. "Only rented," didn't
buy. "Only a Volkswagen," no big deal.
The same thing happens if I put it at the
end of a sentence. "Yesterday I rented a Volkswagen
only." It can't shine its light to the right
'cause there ain't nothin' to the right. So
it goes back on the Volkswagen.
In other words, if I say, "Only a Volkswagen,"
the meaning is the same as, "a Volkswagen
only" period. Because there's only one word
that "only" can shine its light on and that
is the word "Volkswagen."
I'm hearing "onlys" thrown in too soon all
the time. And yet when I hear them I don't
say, "Hey, hey, hey you're 'only' should have
been a little you know, a little bit later
you didn't wait." You know -
[laughter]
No, certainly not. But I note it and that's
how you know noting and noting and seeing
and hearing and reading and all these years
is, is what made me distill the most common
problems for people whose grasp of the language
is firm and put them in this little book.
You can, I'm so happy that you, I don't have
to convince you to get this book, you have
this book; it's in front of you. I, I hope
only that you enjoy it.
See most people would say, "I only hope,"
wouldn't they? Isn't that common? "I only
hope that you enjoy it." "I only hope," that's
all I'm doing is hoping. What a small action
hoping is. It is what I'm trying to say? No.
I'm trying to say, "I hope only one thing."
"I hope only that you'll enjoy it." Interesting,
huh?
Now you're gonna start hearing all the premature
"onlys" in the sentences around you. They're
plentiful, believe me.
Anybody else have a question?
Yes.
>>male in audience: Well thank you first Janis
for, for joining us. It's been a pleasure
and I assure you that if we see anybody in
this room saying "only" or "whether" inappropriate,
or "only" or "if" inappropriately we'll make
sure to call them out.
>>Janis Bell: [laughs]
>>male in audience: But I was actually curious
you said you haven't seen a lot of trends
except for the inside the quotation marks
period, comma, whatever.
In the writing of your students have you seen
any just general abilities changing, better
or worse? I've actually heard a teacher say
or claim that the writing has gotten better
since the Internet age because we're more
comfortable with our medium, the computer,
and we're also more concise in general. I
don't if that's a good thing or a bad thing,
but have you seen any trends like that change
since the real innovation of the computer?
>>Janis Bell: Honestly no. When the word processor
first came into being people were saying,
"Oh, it's gonna make everybody's writing so
much better." Well it made it easier to type,
it made it easier to correct, but the grammar
and the usage and the punctuation were exactly
the same. And the same thing with the way
computers are now days, I mean they make,
they make the process of writing the easiest
it can possibility be and that's wonderful
and you can, ah, you can do anything you wanna
do and embellish it in any way you want, but
people's understanding of the language hasn't
changed. And therefore I don't, I would say
that perhaps it's gotten a little less formal
which our whole society has gotten.
Language has gotten less formal because of
popularity of email and the frequency with
which we now write to one another. But, you
know, I'm constantly seeing "i-t apostrophe
s" where it doesn't belong all over the email.
I'm seeing commas in between complete sentences.
Complete sentence comma, complete sentence
comma, complete sentence period. Just because
they're short and they're related people don't
know how to join 'em. So I don't see that
changing, I really don't.
[pause]
>>male in audience: One last question.
>>Janis Bell: If I did I wouldn't have a job.
[laughter]
[pause]
>>commentator: Alright. Well, thank you again,
Janis for joining us. It's been a pleasure
and I'm sure you'll be staying around to answer
any other last questions you didn't want to
throw out in the mic.
>>Janis Bell: I sure will and I also wanna
tell people to feel free to go to my Website
which is janisbell.com. J-a-n-i-s is the Janis
part. And there's a little bit of information
and even a song that I sing to greet you.
You'll, you'll enjoy it.
[laughter]
>>Janis Bell: [laughs]
>>female in audience: Janis is also gonna
be sticking around to sign books if anybody's
interested in that.
>>Janis Bell: Thanks so much.
[applause]